let's talk about some of the great
innovations that are happening at local
levels in our workplaces across the
country if you're like me i'm sure
you're frustrated with the gridlock that
is blocking any progress in public
policy in Washington I've seen this go
on for 30 years in our field where
Congress and the president can't pass
anything because there's a impasse
between business and labor unemployment
and labor policy so we need to look to
other places for innovations today the
good news is that there's a lot going on
at the local level in established
companies in startups and state and
local governments in nonprofits and so
that's where historically most of our
major innovations that at work have
occurred so let's look at a few of these
you've heard of companies such as
Southwest Airlines started in nineteen
seventy it's the most profitable airline
in the United States it has consistently
been rated as one of the best places to
work it has great customer satisfaction
and it has low prices and it's worked
effectively for shareholders and for
employees and for customers for many
years so that's one example but there
are others across almost every industry
we can find good companies that are able
to provide good jobs at high profits and
good service to their customers in the
health care area you often hear about
Kaiser Permanente a major nonprofit
healthcare provider that both is an
insurer and clinics and doctors offices
and has hospitals Google as you all know
is one of the greatest employers today
it's got the resources to have parties
on Fridays and treat employees well and
encourage them to work creatively on
their own work you're in New England we
celebrate the work of Market Basket one
of our grocery chains where employees
went on strike to support their CEO to
save the business culture and the
business that was good for employees and
good for customers and good for
shareholders we'll talk more about
Market Basket in
your sessions of this class on the west
coast there's a similar organization
called in and out burgers again a retail
restaurant which is doing very very well
so there are companies that do this and
then there are new forms of work
emerging out of the so-called on-demand
economy with names like uber TaskRabbit
companies that disrupt traditional ways
of organizing work and that bring
customers more directly into the work
process we will discuss the pros and the
cons of these new ways of working
throughout this course and we see
equally exciting innovations all across
the world the Swedish furniture maker
IKEA for example is a global leader in
environmental sustainability in serving
low-income customers with good quality
furniture at reasonable prices and
providing good working conditions
including ensuring that its lowest paid
employees earn a living wage or consider
semko an innovative company in Brazil
that has gained a reputation for
empowering employees to control their
own jobs and their work schedules and
yet has grown to become Brazil's most
successful company the CEO who grew and
shaped the company Ricardo Semler was
recognized by the world economic forum
as one of the global leaders of tomorrow
but what about innovations on the labor
market side well in the 20th century
unions were the source of tremendous
innovation they're happy to tell you
that they are the group that brought you
the weekend and in fact that's true they
negotiated for time off for holidays for
weekends for various kinds of vacation
pay and sick leave pay but unions as you
can see here have fallen on hard times
they have lost membership going from
about a third of the workforce down to
less than fifteen percent today and in
the private sector they're even lower at
about seven percent but in the wake of
this decline we're seeing new forms of
worker organization emerge sometimes
they are called cooperatives sometimes
they're called worker centers sometimes
they're
fast food strikes as we've seen against
McDonald's and other industries
sometimes it's protests against Walmart
on Black Friday where workers are
protesting low wages in that industry
but we're seeing these organizations
come along and develop their own form of
innovation that helps to represent
workers and provide workers a voice that
that allows them to improve their own
conditions on the job and some are using
social media to provide new
opportunities you've heard about
mechanical turk which provides jobs for
people who can sign up on the internet
to do coding jobs and other very basic
kinds of things that they can do from
home well this thing called turkic
opticon has come along and it said we
will rate employers are they good
employers can we trust them do they pay
their employees wages on time do they
live up to their promise this is all
done spontaneously to organize so we're
seeing new forms of organization like
this come along so we can do this we
need to continue to put our our good
faith efforts into creating innovations
at the workplace we need to ask then how
can we take those innovations and spread
them across the economy so that more and
more people can benefit from these good
ideas that's our job I look forward to
seeing more innovations and I look
forward to seeing what you and your
generation creates as the next form of
work the next kind of organizations that
will meet the needs of our economy and
our society going forward
you